[موسيقى]
يعطيكم العافيه
بدي من الجميع يعمل مثلي هيك
كمان مره هدى لجوا
طلعوا لبرا يعطيكم العافيه بدي كل واحد
يطلع على جنبه ويقول له انا بحبك كتير بس
من نفس الجنس
[تصفيق]
طيب اجمل شي بالحياه انك تبتسم بس الاجمل
باكثر من هيك انك ترسم بسمه شفاف بالك واي
واحد صفر صح ولا صح
[تصفيق]
شباب في يوم من الايام كان في عندي حلم
كنت من انا صغير اتفرج على ابطال العالم
هل ممكن ان يكون بطل العالم هل ممكن اني
اصير مثل ابطال العالم قلت اشوفهم هم عم
بيبكوا
[موسيقى]
اقول يا رب نفسي اكون مثلهم يا الله هيك
اتامل هذيك اللحظه اللي بتنزل بدي اصير
مثلهم اذا بده يكون عندك حلم بهاي الحياه
لازم انه يكون عندك غايه ولازم انه يكون
عندك هدف ولغايه ايش ايش هي الغايه مجموعه
من الاحلام او الاهداف لهيك شباب دائما
لازم يكون في عندك اصرار ولازم يكون في
عندك عزيمه ولازم يكون في عندك قوه وما
تياس بحياتك يوم من الايام كان في صديق
لنا
او معروف لدى الجميع مستوبيشي هذا الانسان
كان ماشي طالع بسيارته او طالع بتاكسي
مثله مثل اي حدا فقابل شوفير التكسير صار
يحكي له انا حاسس عندي طاقات كتير عائله
وحاسس عندي قوه كثير عاليه بس مش عارف شو
بدي اعمل بحياتي مش عارف شو بدي اعمل قال
له روح عند العمده فلان
ركزوا شباب عشان كيف بدنا نبدا الحلم
تبعنا كيف بدنا نوصل لاهدافنا كيف بدنا
نصير ابطال العالم
قال له روح انا العمده فلانه راح عند فلان
دق عليه الباب اول مره اول مره طلعت له
مرته قالت له فلان مش موجود تعالوا بعد ست
شهور بعد شهور ست شهور اجاك كمان مره نفس
القصه كمان ثلاث شهور اخر اشي قالت له بدي
اخليك تشوفه
قعد معه اول ما قعد معاه شو قال له قاعد
يقول له انا وصار يتدمر مثل شباب اليوم
ومثل احنا وبدي اصير وبدي اعمل له احكي لي
ايش بدك قال له بدي اكون ناجح ومتزن قال
له لا لازم تكون متزن ثم ناجح يعني
الانسان يا شباب اللي بده يكون ناجح
بحياته بده يكون عنده اتزاني كتير بعدين
حتى انك توصل للنجاح وفعليا هذا الانسان
اليوم احنا كلنا بنسمع عنه وبنعرف عنه صار
عنده ماركت ميتسوبيشي للسيارات بس ايش هذا
بيميزه هذا الشخص انه كان عنده عناد كان
عنده اصرار كان عنده عزيمه كمان اعطيني
اياها
كمان اي ميتسوبيشي
ايوه هون خليك
شباب حتى انك توصل وحتى انك توصل لحلمك
بالله ركزوا معي كثير
يجب ان يكون عندك نموذج بشري حي يوم من
الايام كنت بحدى البطولات ففي لاعب مكسيكي
كل ما اعمل اشي بعمل مثلين بيعمل مثلي كل
ما اعمل اشي بعمل مثلي حتى انه وصل بالشكل
بالشكل بالشكل اللي صار يعمل المتري فانا
ناديته قلت له شو موضوعك انت معلم طبعا
بالانجليزي شو موضوعك انت كل ما اعمل اشي
بتعمل مثلي قال لي مش انت بطل العالم في
رفع الاثقال طبعا انا مش من كمان رفع
الاثقال قلت له انا بطلع انا في رفع
الاثقال قال انت بترفع 230 كيلو جرام
قال لي انا عم بعمل كل اشي مثلك حتى اني
اكون بطل العالم بقول له ليه قال لي لانه
ببساطه انت ما وصلت لهاي المرحله وصرت بطل
عالم ببلاش شباب اليوم مش غلط انه يكون في
عنا نموذج بشري حي انقلدوا بكل شيء احنا
عم نعمله نصير ابطال العالم
كرمال انك تكون بطل وين المشكله اني اكون
بطل العالم مثل الدكتور بالجامعه او
الدكتوره بالجامعه او اكون بطل العالم في
بيتي في مطبخي في كل مكان انت ممكن تكون
بطل العالم بس اهم اشي انك تتصالح مع ذاتك
وتوصل
للعدف اللي انت بدك اياه كمان
الشباب اليوم الاشي الحلو كثير لما يجي
معتز عم بحكي لكم عن قصته او عن قصه نجاحه
كثير يكون مستمعين لانه معتز اليوم عم
بيعطيكم عن خبره مر فيها خلال مراحل
وبالنهايه وصل للنجاح فانت اذا اردت انك
تكون ناجح بحياتك يجب انك تكون مستمع جيد
ويجب انك تاخذ خبره من السابقين ويجب انك
تسمع استاذك ويجب انك تنسط لكل الناس الي
هاي عم بتقدم لك باي فرير منك اشي وبداش
منك مصالح كمان
هذا يوم من الايام يا صبايا كان في صبيتين
حلوات مثلكم
هذول مش زي الشباب
هدول الصفيتين كانت وحده عازبه صاحبيتها
عندها على طبخه السمك تمام
فلما عزمتها اجت دخلت عندها المطبخ لتساعد
لتساعدها فاول ما دخلت عندها شافت امها
وهي عم تعمل ايش بتنفع راس السمكه فانا
ليش انت عم تقطعي راس السمكه
يعني شو المشكله التي لا والله ما بعرف
امي كانت تعمل هيك رحنا لقومها فقلنا
لقومها ليش انت عم تعملي هيك قالت والله
ما بعرف جدتي كانت تعمل هيك وصلنا للجده
ببساطه ليش بتعملي هيك قالت والله بصراحه
الصينيه كانت صغيره ما كانت تدوس على
السمكه فقلت اضطر اني اقطع راس السمكه
ببساطه شو بتعلمنا هاي الشغله انه صبايا
شباب بلا ما نتعود من الاشياء السلبيه
ونطبقها بحياتنا يجب انه يكون محللين
جيدين كمان
شباب هل يوجد فشل بالنجاح
هل يوجد فشل بالنجاح
مين بحكي اه يا عيني عليك طب مين بحكي لا
مين بحكي لا ليش
يا عيني عليك يا عيني عليك لانه ببساطه
اسمها شباب لا يوجد لا يوجد فشل بالنجاح
ولكن يوجد تجارب غير ناجحه تقول الى نجاح
اعظم صح اللي فرصه في التوجيه انتهت حياته
طب ما هو بعيد ثاني مره بصير معاه ماجستير
بكالوريوس صح
هذا يوم من الايام يا شباب يا صبايا واحد
كان يشتغل بتسعه وعشرين شركه التسعه
وعشرين شركه سكروا وراح صاحبنا لا اعلان
هيك بسيط دخل عليه الاعلان سال على
الاعلان قالوا له شو الاكسبيريان عندك
مياده اول سؤال بسالوك اياه قال لهم والله
انا اشتغلت ب 29 شركه 29 شركه سكر قالوا
له يعني جاي تطبق الثلاثين قال لهم لا قال
لهم لا مش 30 انا جاي اليوم احكي لكم عن
29 تجربه غير ناجحه عشان ما تصير عندكم
فاليوم لا يوجد فشل بالنجاح ولكن يوجد
تجارب غير ناجحته الاعظم صح ولا صح ما
تنسوها
يا الله يا الله يا الله يا الله مقواهم
ودول الناس اللي عندهم عطاء يا الله دول
شبابنا المتطوعين اللي بنشوفهم في كل مكان
يا الله هدول الشباب شو رائعينهم يا الله
هدول الناس
من طاقاتهم بتعرفوا هدول شو هدول من كتر
ما عندهم عطاء لنفسهم صار عندهم فائض صار
يعطوا للاخرين فاخواني دائما اعطي كل
الناس لانه يوم من الايام راح تيجي وتحتاج
الناس اللي حواليك فراح يكونوا واقفين
معاك بينما لو ما معك عندك عطاء للناس
الناس ما بتعطيك صح ولا صح صح ولا صح
تمام شباب بحياتك لا تقول تابعك ولا ترضى
انك تقول تابعه ولا تكون امها دائما خطط
لنفسك الشباب اهم اشي في طريق النجاح
صبايا التخطيط لبنان اهم شيء بالحياه خطط
لنفسك حتى ما تكون تابعه لانه اذا جيت
اليوم علي وقلت لي كابتن معتز خطط لي انا
بدي اخطط لك وانت تصير تابع لالي زي ما
بدي انا بدك تمشي ما عجبتنيش بالتمسيس
فدائما خبطت لنفسك حتى انك توصل لها كمان
شباب في قبل ما نوصل لهون
كل شخص منا موجود هون بحكي لكم سر بس ما
تحكوا لحدا
كل شخص عندكم موجود عنا هون في ميزات كثير
ربنا عز وجل من يخلق الانسان بيخلق معاه
كثير الطاقات وبخلق معاه كتير ميزات كم
صبيه عنا موجوده هون ارفعوا ايديكم
اسمعيني وانت رافعه ايدك وانت رافعه ايدك
اترك الموبايل
لكل صبيه موجوده هون انت
عم تسمعوني صبايا عم تسمعوني لكل صبيه
موجوده هون انت كتير حلوه
لكل صبيه انت موجوده هون انت كتير بتجنني
ولك يا نيالك بكل ديانات السماويه الله
حكى عنك والناس بتحكي عنك بكل مكان انت ام
انت رائعه
عشان الشباب ما يزعلوا منا
كم سب نسمه موجود هون
يا عيني يسعدهم لكل رائع موجود هون يعني
نيالك يا نسمه يا نيالك يا رائع
سميناك ربي الاسره لانك توصل ليل من
النهار كرمال ناس كرمال اولادك كرمال
اسرتك تطلع
برد صيف كرمال انك تحكي ناس في نيالك يا
عظيم يا نيالك يا رائع
شباب كل انسان موجود في عنده طاقات كثير
هائله وعندهم امتيازات عائله لا يوجد لا
يوجد في هذه الحياه اسمعوها لا يوجد في
هذه الحياه شخص ضعيف ولكن يوجد شخص لا
يبحث عن ميزاته صح ولا صح ما تنسوها
شباب لما يكون عنا مشكله
في يوم من الايام هاي القصه بدي احكي لكم
اياها كانبسط طلاب
فباسط الطلاب هذا كان ماشيين في طلاب
والاساد والى اخره
بتعرفوا اي سياره بالدنيا من قدام منخفضه
شوي لانه الموتور
بس من ورا بتكون رافعه دخل الباص هذا
النفق علق
لما علق الباص هذا صار فيه مشكله طب كيف
بدنا نطلعه جابوا الونشات بدهم يهدوا
الجسر شو بدنا نعمل ما لقوا ولا اي طريقه
حدا بحكي لي شو عملو
عارفين القصه
شو عملوا
يا عيني عليك يا عيني عليك
اساهم سب
شطور مثل الاستاذ قال لهم الموضوع سهل لا
تهدوا الجسر ولا تنسوا راسل هاي بس نفسه
بعجال نزل العجال شوي 2 سم سهل الباص
ببساطه الشباب للاسف احنا في هاي
المجتمعات منعيش المشكله اكثر ما بنعيش
الحلول وهاي هي الكارثه شباب اذا اردت انك
تطلع من المشكله يجب انك تجزئها وبعدين
تدور عن حلول رح احكي لكم شي قلت فيه كل
يوم اروح فيه على مدرستي امشي على
العكازات امشي ثلاث ساعات روحه وثلاث
ساعات جايه واربع ساعات بالمدرسه هاي عشر
ساعات يعني يومي كله بالمدرسه بس بالنهايه
كان عندي ادب وكنت دائما ادور على الحلول
كرمال اني احلها وكنت ما اعيش المشكله
واقول انا شاب من ذوي الاعاقه وصعب الامور
وخلص ما بدي اروح على المدرسه لا كان عندي
امل وهدف انه لازم اني اتعب فالشباب
اذا اردت انكم تطبقوا حلمكم يجب انكم ما
تعيشوا المشكله بل تعيش الهلول اكثر من
المشكله حتى توصل لهدفك ما بدي اطول كثير
عليكم لانه انا بحكي كثير ومحاضرات كتير
مليانه موجوده على الميديا باسم معتزل
الجنيدي كل مواقع الميديا باسم معتزل
جنيدي بالعربي والانجليزي ولكن اللي بدي
احكي لكم اياه ببساطه اذا اردت انك تكوني
بطله عالم في بيتك في مكانك في كل مكان
يجب ان يكون عندك هدف ويجب انه يكون عندك
غرض من الحياه والغرض من الحياه مجموعه
اهداف ويجب انه يكون عندك اصرار ويجب انه
يكون عندك عزيمه ودائما امن ان الله يعطي
اصعب المعارك لمين لاقوى جنوده واحنا اقوى
وجنوده
بدي اورجيكم مجموعه صور بس اتوقع انه هاي
الشاشه مش كتير واضحه بس يلا خلينا نمشي
كمان
هاي صورتي مع جلاله الملك تم تكريمي اكثر
من ست مرات من جلاله الملك وانا واحد من
الناس اللي اسسوا هيا الشباب
هاي الصوره مش مبينه من مره بس اجمل ما
فيها ابتسم يا شباب كلما صعبت ابتسم ليش
لان الابتسامه هي الدقه الوحيده اللي تقدر
تدخل فيها قلوب الناس صح ابتسم كمان
احلى واحد احلى واحد اللي ماسك الطابه
البيضاء كمان
هون انا مثلت الشباب الاردني وحكيت عن
روائع الشباب الاردني والعرب وكل الناس في
الكونغرس الامريكي وكان اشي كتير حلو كمان
شباب اوعى تقول لي الاردن اولا او ارفع
راسك انت اردني وانت ما عندك هذا الموضوع
شعور حقيقي يجب انه يكون عندك هذا الموضوع
شعور وليس شعار كمان هاي صرخه انا بخاف
منها اقلب
شباب في شيء اسمه قانون الجذب كل ما توصل
لاشي اطلب اطلب اطلب من الحياه وكل ما
تطلب شاكر كمان كمان
عندي اكثر من 200 محاضره اعطيت كل
الجامعات وكل الاماكن بكل المحافظات
بالبلد كمان شباب بدي اورجيكم اشي بس يا
ريت كانت النظاره منيحه عشان اورجيكم انه
بعد هاي الصوره لا يوجد صعب ولا يوجد
مستحيل وكل شيء في هذه الحياه ممكن لا
يوجد صعب ولا يوجد مستحيل وكل شيء في هذه
الحياه سوء
خلينا نشوف الصوره
انا عم بتسلق جبال
[تصفيق]
اللي بعده هلا انا ومجموعه من اصحابي عم
نعمل على لندخل
الانس في جنس في سحب شاحنه وزنها 25 طن
على الكراسي المتحرك اخواني اصحابي
في هذه الحياه لا يوجد صعب ولا يوجد
مستحيل وكل شيء في هذه الحياه ممكن انا
انا لست بحاجه لاقدام لاسير في هذه الحياه
انا انا لست بهذا الاقدام
انا لست اسمعوني شوي انا لست بحاجه لاقدام
لاسير في هذه الحياه وانما بحاجه لاقدام
انا لست بحاجه عيون لارى من احب ولست
بحاجه ليدين لاضمر من احب بايماني بنفسي
وبربي ارى واغمر من كل من احب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]